good morning and good afternoon Welcome
to our perama webinar more predictive
results and sbed essays by combining
Target based and phenotypic approaches
using our new inside multi mod plade
reader let me get started by introducing
our speakers so my name is H I'm the
portfolio director for multim mode
detection and I'm based in Hamburg in
Germany now we'll give you an
introduction on our new
insight the second talk will be given by
Norbert Garo Norbert is our principal
application scientist based in Hamburg
as well and he will give you more
insights into the new cell imaging
technology our guest speaker Phil gribin
from the frown hoer IM screening p and
he is the head of the screening will
give you a presentation on uh aay
development for anti Cancer
drugs so what will you learn in this
webinar first of all how you can combine
cell Imaging with labeled and label free
Technologies to gain more predictive
results in the drug Discovery
process how to improve your data quality
and reduce your cost in sale based
assets by using our recently launched
inside multimode Plate
Reader last but not least Le and that is
part of the last talk given by Phil
inside cell Imaging how this approach
can give you new insights and new um
ideas for anti-cancer drug
Discovery before we go into the details
I just like to give you the big picture
for perk and Elma and how we hope and
support you for translational
research what we mean by that is that we
want to reduce the cost per data point
and gives you more clinical
relevance now we talk about the inside
and these are the first steps in the
process so what is the inside multim
mode reader with cell
Imaging first of all it's the only
benchtop system to offer multim mode
detection Alpha label free and imaging
on
board you have a through orthogonal
approach which means you can run Target
based essays phenotypic assays or
combination of the two and last but not
least you have a new image based hometry
module on board which can be used for
four colors bright field digital face
Imaging at high speed when we talk about
high speed we mean four minutes per
color to read a 3841
plate so what type of AES can can you
run on the
inside before we go into details I'd
like to draw the picture for our
portfolio so for biochemical essays we
have the lab ship easy reader Mobility
shift essays and as you can see here you
can divide it all essays in the
biochemical space or cell-based essay
space now I'd like to draw your
attention on integrated well part of
cellb ases which basically means you get
one well for your s best essay has
readout and here we have the Victor The
Envision and the view luux now new on
board is the
inside now I'd like to draw your
attention to the right side to cell
Imaging for cell best essays here we
have sub cellular resolution and here we
offer the
operator as well as the recently
launched operator Phoenix
what not really perfectly is covered is
the space in between what we call
hydrometry and now with the new insight
plus the Imaging capability we fill this
Gap we build the bridge for cellular s
is and that is the new exciting thing to
present
today so what can the Insight
offer let's get started for the multim
mode detection world so firstly you have
a true orthogonal system for Target
based phenotypic or the combination you
can run all conventional MMD
Technologies plus label free and the
cell Imaging in one
workflow I've mentioned already the fast
image-based ceter
module important to know is that all
Technologies are field
upgradable and it's perfectly suited for
the mid-range market and
budget now we come closer to the high
content world what can the Insight offer
here first of all it's a perfect tool
for simply assay at cellular
resolution again a true orthogonal
approach because the people here get
access to Conventional M andd
Technologies including label free it's
made for the ease of use and no special
training is
required if you take the inside upfront
high content instrumentation you can
free up your high content site you can
use it as a kind of preschool screening
tool last but not least if there any
restriction in terms of budget or space
the inside might be a good
option so in
summary what is the inside new software
on board our Kido software
workflow-based new instrument control
and data structure and we can offer you
customers Imaging data
evaluation
Hardware a new look and
feel we've added new technologies on
board and as I already pointed out all
Technologies are field
upgradable the cell Imaging is the new
exciting technology on board you have
single cell resolution for example for
set counting you have a fast 9 6 384
well reading and you can combine it with
conventional M&D
Technologies so what other features do
you
have first of all the fast flexible and
Powerful software it's workflow based
and we integrate it in the background
our Capa acapella engine which is well
known in the high content world for fast
data analysis
I've pointed already out the modular
design for all technology that gives you
a customized tailored system to your
current needs and budget and you are
ready for future
upgrades with the integration of Imaging
you have access to image-based
fluorescence labeled or multicolor
essays and two stainless methods like
brightfield and digital face contrast
Imaging you can use this to increase the
quality of your sbas assays
and Norbert will give you more insights
in this
part in addition we have a special
Perkin Elma owned Optical design which
includes laser fast autofocus and a
scientific seos camera with this you
have high performance at low light and
high
speed mentioned already our capella so
we have pre-written data analyze modules
which helps you to analyze in an easy
way the cell Imaging part and you get
leverage of over of over over 10 years
experiences in high
content last but not least you have a
broad range of application multim mode
detection label free and imaging ready
to go for multiplexing or aoral
workflows so here you
have our nice software the cido at a
glance let me walk you a bit through on
the top is the
workflow which helps you to set up a
protocol run a
protocol and uh reanalyze your
data on the left side you can select
your Technologies of interest for
example Alpha label free Imaging time
resolved whatever is of your interest
on the right
side you find the plate map here you can
determine the number of positive
negative
controls um
unknown and standard
concentrations in the Centum you have
the content area here you'll find graphs
or results so in summary quick and easy
setup and you can run your essays with
use of pre-programmed protocols you can
anal Anze and reanalyze your data you
can do it on the instrument PC or in
your
office and last but not least you get
displayed your results as numerical list
graph plate VI or
seat so what kind of Technologies can
you find on the inside multim mode
reader I go from the right to the left
side absorbance fluorescent bottom and
top reading time resolved
florescence Ultra sensitive
luminescence Alpha technology Epic Level
fre and now our well
Imaging with this Technologies on board
you can leun different essays in one
workflow here you see the
overview so Alpha
essays fluorescence essays absorbance of
course lens or deia essays luminescence
essays like our ATP light the Epic label
free essays and now on top image based
citometry which gives you access to
fluoresence bride field and digital face
energy now I'd like to come a step
closer to the well Imaging module and
you will get in a second more details
given by Norbert
so what do you find here first of all we
have four LEDs for excitation so in the
UV range in the blue range in the green
and in the
red on top we have emission light which
is
required for bride feet and digital
digital face contrast we have a very
fast laser based autofocus which help us
for short reading times
we have a very sensitive seos camera
which helps us to read at high speed and
a very sensitive
way and we have a special Optical design
more details to come byor and last but
not least all these Technologies are
combinable with other multi mode
detection I'd like to stop here with an
overview of different
applications so what can you done what
can you do with our new module cell
counting and
normalization cell talkx AES like life
de apoptosis
proliferation can have a closer look to
cell migration cell signaling like repor
genes it's a perfect tool for phenotypic
assay and here they will give us more
details and clone
selection important to understand is all
these type of essd I'm very sure there
more to come you can run at cellular
resolution in an endpoint or kinetic
mode for fixed or life
cells and again combinable in one
workflow with conventional MMD
Technologies or label free and that
leads you to the Holy Grail of
orthogonal
Confirmation and with this I'd like to
hand over to Norbert for the second part
of our
talk we'll see his slides now yeah sorry
I have I forgot at the end we have
reserved about 10 minutes for question
and answers yeah so please if you have
questions in between type in your
questions on the left field thanks thank
you f for this
introduction as F already point out the
inside is capable to run all the
currently available M World detection
Technologies plus Imaging so I'm going
to focus on the Imaging opportunity
only as a starting point some more
background on on the Optics we designed
the instrument and the optic in a way
that we can ensure single cell Optical
resolution and ensure also a very large
field of view to focus on good
Statistics over many cells so we can
easily image a full Val 38 384 Val
plates even for 96 Val plate we almost
get a complete well
the typical resolution is roughly three
microns of the sample per pixel on the
camera which is sufficient for single s
resolution we
have up to four fluoresence channels
with using different LEDs for excitation
plus the two Imaging modes bright field
and digital phas imaging which do not
rely on any fluorescent stain but also
do not interfere with them
we know that image analysis can
sometimes be a very tedious story if you
have to set it up uh coming from the
high content world with a lot of
background in there and using the proven
algorithm coming from there we did
invest quite a lot of work to simplify
the image evaluation task for the user
and prepared a set of predefined
evaluation methods which cover a large
range of different
applications
this selection of evaluation methods for
image EV image analysis will continue to
grow and is also
customization tunable for customer
applications you've seen this figure
before um the Imaging module consists
well you have the sample carrier of
course which holds um to
Sals face so image the for for
magnification lens we have a set of
fluoresence excitation
diets uh and we have a
multiband diic optic to separate
excitation band and fluoresence emerging
from the sample
carrier so if it excites the sample we
just need to switch on a single
LED that excites the sample the
fluoresence emerging from the sample is
imaged through the multiband detection
objects onto the seos camera if you now
want to switch to a different wavelength
we just can switch on the next LED and
do the same story in another color so we
don't need any mechanical movement to
switch between wavelength which speeds
up the whole measurement process
significantly at the end we come up for
a 384 well plate with typically four
minutes in a single color and five
minutes in a dual color
measurement
as an example for fluorescence images we
have here a two-color experiment the
nucle has have been stained with s the
cytoplasm using a microt Tracker marker
and the overlay results in a colored
image my personal favorite currently is
however the stainless Imaging and for
this we can use the fifth LED in the
imag module which is placed above the
sample it illuminates the cells from
behind and the cells are then imaged by
the microscopic setup onto the camera as
before the figure here shows the field
of youu in a brightfield image you can
see easily that on the left
panel more than a well of a 384 well
plate is imaged with one shot if you
look carefully you may be able to see
also the next Bell looking at the rim of
the picture the right side is of course
for 96 W plate where we can image most
of the do just a little ring uh little
pieces cut on top and in the bottom how
much is cut of course depends on the
sample carrier in
Muse you also notice that the intensity
distribution in these vs is bit be with
a bright Center and decreasing towards
the rim of the plate of the valve this
is due to the liquid surface of the
sample carrier and this distorts
actually the intensity distribution of
the valve but the image analysis does
handle this properly and it does not
disturb the
results by the way the figures you have
seen in the last slide are the only one
which shows a full view of the camera
this slide deck the next images are all
cut down to the size of the Val or even
further for detailed
views here I have a comparison for the
two stainless Imaging modes the bright
image on the side here you can nicely
hopefully you can detect in this display
the the individual cells uh but they are
not clearly separated from the
background in the digital face image on
the right side I'll we
did add quite some mathematics to
clarify the display for individual CS
the picture actually looks quite similar
to a nuclear stain but it is free of any
stain indeed the digital face image is
just calculated from Bright food
images it does not require any special
add-on optic Optics as you may be
familiar with from the face contrast
microscopy
the digital face image can also be used
to segment individual cells as a
starting point for further analysis of
florescence essays or to characterize or
just count the Sal and
ail a here set of Imaging applications
on the inside we are currently working
on and for the the Pres rest of the
presentation I would like to focus on
few starting applications like say
counting using different
methods like quality control using no
stain at
all or using a stainless life de
essay so this figure displays two
different cell types on the left side
a431 cells on the right side he cells at
different Den cell densities you can
clearly see that the boosts they
nually allocated in different grow
patterns so the heer cells are quite
evenly distributed over the valve while
the a41 cells grow in
patches for both cell types it's pretty
easy to segment a cell as a cell signal
individual
objects this is done in the top display
of this figure you may recall the bow
shaped cell group here in the center of
the image which was shown before it's
also shown in the figure below and it
will come up in the next figures as
well
um the nuclear stain easy easily allows
to count the cells in the confluency
analysis on the lower
display we cannot count individual cells
but estimate or calculate the area that
is covered by
CS as you see already by eye the degree
of confluency is much higher in this
case for the Healer cells than for the
a41s in this display we again have the O
shaped group of cells here in the um C
counting image but we did not use the
nuclear stain in the top display but
just the digital face image and for the
left side including the segmentation
information for comparison the bo State
figures are shown
below and they look on the first side
very similar here if you look closely
you may find some
differences so we did compare SE numbers
and S densities using four different
methods of course during the seaing we
had the cell counter for the different
cells uh and determined the seeding
density of the cells we used nuclear
staining to count the individual nucle
using a fluorescent we
out we did cell counting using digital
face Imaging without taking the nuclear
stain into
account and we did determine the degree
of confluency also without using the
staining information all these four
methods correlate
nicely for the following parts we need a
bit more background on the determination
of confluency what you can see in this
figure is a detailed view of healer
cells which nicely attach to the uh
through the Val so most cells
are wi expanded there are a few cells
that are rounded
up and what you can see in these area
covered by cells are basically intensity
fluctuation caused by the cells and the
intensity basically follows the shape of
the
cells in the background areas which are
not covered by cells there is virtually
no change of the signal on the size
scale of a
cell and actually the method that
calculates the confluency does
calculate on the changes of intensity on
the cell size scale we call this texture
parameter roughness so it's a
specialized evaluation for this kind of
analysis as you can see here
the rounded up cells on top also give
quite significant result results in the
roughness parameter and this may be
quite helpful for future analysis of
specific
cells therefore the confluency
calculation does not only return the
expected degree of confluency so
percentage of the area covered by Sals
in this case I think it was something
like
35% it also gives information on the the
roughness parameter the intensity of
this texture structure in the cellular
area which we name foreground roughness
it gives information on the this
parameter in the background and on
the maximum compared to the minimum
roughness values in the Val which
sometimes cause y surprising additional
insights into your
sounds what can we do with simple dfield
Imaging but it's quite obvious that one
of the most important appli ations might
be just a simple control of cell culture
in the left
figure we have the cells as we expect
them they are not disturbed by anything
and grow with a medium degree of
confluency the center and right display
are somewhat Disturbed for the center
display during sou seedings there was a
bubble on top of the liquid which skewed
up the
uh the cell seeding procedure and also
the right side uh there was the cell
layer was scratched using a piper
tip this can easily be detected with
this kind of
analysis sometimes we can also get some
surprises on the left display here we
see mcf7 cells which attach nicely to
the cell area the
cells in the C covered area there are
some objects which are rounded up
probably dead cells
and between the C covered area there is
literally nothing just plain Gray
Line on the right side we have a well
that has been contaminated by bacteria
the
bacteria destroys the cells so the
roughness within the cell covered area
reduces pretty much on the other side
the cells also grow on the bottom of the
Val and increase the texture parameter
here so the range of textures
significantly reduced and that's a
parameter that is independent on any
threshold for confluency determination
and really it's helpful to determine is
there any strange artifacts are coming
up of course we can use the
determination of confluency also for
some basic essays like life life dead
essay without using any fluorescent
stain on the left side we have healer
cells that have been incubated without
DMSO these cells are spread out as we
are used to there are some but not very
many dead cells or rounded up cells on
the right side the same number of cells
has been incubated with about 4% DMSO
overnight and in this case the cells are
rounded up they use only a very small
area they to cover uh and have as
rounded up s a larger contrast so the
texture is
increased if you check uh for this essay
we compare the confluency prior to cell
treatment with the confluency after cell
treatment and if we do this for all the
concentrations available we see on the
left display that the area covered by
Sal the degree of confluency increased
with low concentrations of DMSO so we
get positive numbers
here with higher concentration of DMSO
of course the Confluence decreases the
sou to
shrink actually was a bit of a surprise
to see that
with about 0.5% DMS these Sals seem to
grow even faster so here the Confluence
increased from something like uh 35% to
about 40
44% uh growing by roughly
8% on the right side the display shows
the texture parameter found in the area
of the cells also compared
after incubation with a value before
incubation the slow Dem o concentrations
we find that the texture was reduced
during the incubation time
at higher DMSO concentration of course
the texture increases indicating
rounding up of the
cells what might lead to a reduction of
the texture during
incubation most likely in this case
there have been dead cells already
before treatment which have as they are
rounded up quite some impact on the
average texture
parameter during the
ciation the death cells did not grow but
the still healthy other cells did grow
did continue to grow and just the
fraction of healthy cells became larger
and the average roughness parameter
decrease
with so I did show you that the confu
determination is a valueable tool to
analyze your
cells be it for quality control to label
cell wels that might be somewhat
affected by disturbances or just to
confirm that everything is perfect as
you would like to see it can also be
used for some
essays I did show you that the digital
face images can be used to count cells
even without any
stain that can also be used as a
sale segmentation information in
combination for example with fluoresence
for transaction rate analysis without
any need of additional
State I did not show you some other
methods we are working on like migration
essays and with that I would like to
hand over to Phil so thank you very much
no so you give me a second to load up
your
slides okay here they are okay thanks a
lot no thanks lot um so I'm Phil gribin
from the IMA swing port and also based
here in Hamburg and today I want to talk
about some of the work that we're doing
in anti-cancer drug profiling and we
have a a well established setup here and
our standard of or or method of choice
up to now as being ATP quation using a
cell tiw method but in these um
preliminary work on the Insight reader
we've been trying to set up a comparison
with what the types of parameters we can
um get with the the bright field
analysis in terms of confluency and in
terms of M will
we so
quickly so just to just one or two words
about the screening port and who we are
um we're involved in um small molecule
drug Discovery and we have access to
over half a million comp SS and a number
of um automated screening systems
including some froma and we work across
a number of indication areas
particularly CNS NE degenerate diseases
cardiovascular but also we have several
cancer programs we have a biomar group
and working in Translation research
based at the hospital here we have a
particular interest in in life science
informatics and the Data Solutions but I
think what's relevant here is that we um
we work with um organizations s per and
Elma who were developing Noble
Technologies to Aid the C Discovery
process and we want to work with those
to develop and bench those Technologies
to give us better better ways to
identify compounds and subsequently
confirm those compounds so we can incre
increase the chance of translating from
the V to to the
clinic so if we look at um the typical
workflow in um a cell toxicity asset um
in in this case we we've taken on board
the NCI 60 panel from the National
Cancer Institute 60 different cell LS
representing a wide range of different
cancer types and and for those we've
developed and protocols based upon the
the cell typ where we using ATP
determination and those protocols
involve three at four elastic formats
and typically we're seing the cells and
24 hours later we're adding the
compounds incubate for a further 48
hours then we're trying to establish
what the cell viability is there
and in from these types of measurements
we're were able to identify cytic
effects and also cytotoxic effects
um if we look down now to the next slide
and here's just a quick overview of the
ATP detection system I guess most people
know it but I'll give you you wor on it
in this case ATP is used as a detection
of ATP is used as a surrogate for number
of cells so the higher level of ATP you
have and the greater turnover of the bin
oxin and the release ofly and Signal
emerges and we've been doing now
detection of to Now using the clal end
vision of the previous generation of
reader from B Elma and what it gives you
is actually pretty remarkable linearity
between conventionally determined cell
number cells to well um versus the the
luminesence signal and this is some data
from the KA
formula all of our assays are configured
for 20 mic from
form um so this is again just looking
what you would do conventionally with an
ATP determination here in um the panel
on the top left um you're doing your DMs
oance and this is pretty much what
you've seen with um the the um the data
from norit you get a decrease in um cell
viability with increaseing bmso in the
next stage in validating each of these
assets is to check the linearity you can
see here on the second panel this is for
the 786 renal cell cancel line and you
can see actually you get um pretty
remarkable level of linearity from tens
of thousands of cells all the way down
to 700 cells that means you can run out
STS with as low as 1,000 sales for well
quite successfully next stage in in your
Val validation is to look at a set of
standard compounds here we're looking at
the dose responses of a range of
compounds CIS platin six capin storin
taxel and you can see here that those
toxic some some of are less S I think
what's quite interesting is that we
always try to do a counter assd when
we're when we're running these types of
asses and here is an example with CIS
platin whereby we have the the do
responses um for the CIS pattern itself
is the in the do well it's the do line
sorry you can see see here that's coming
down but also if you measure the cell
viability immediately after adding the
compounds you can create a counter assd
and you can see in this case that even
with zero at zero T of incubation you
count R showing
significant um cytotoxic or apparent
cytotoxic effects um which are not real
essentially an artifact in instan
Platinum which is interfering with the
recient report system and this is pretty
much the same as any any normal report
system you're going to have compounds
which will interfere with it and you
really want to try and move away from
that and especially if you're getting
involved skill
comps um as I mentioned now we we're
using the the cell typic rule as a
phenotypic asset so we're looking at a
general gross effect um it is quite
possible and one of the great things
about using the NCI panel is that you
can screen up to 35 to 40 of those um
those cell lines against an individual
compound with an unknown mechanism of
action then you can feed that data into
the um compare algorithm this this
excuse me this compare algorithm
contains information on a number of um
compounds with know mechanisms of action
and also a diversity set of 38,000
compounds and it's the pattern of
activity of your unknown compound can be
used can be deconvoluted and compared
with the activity of nonn compounds and
ative mechanism of action can be
identified and it's always very useful
to have a a phenotypic observation of a
cytostatic or cytotoxic effect but if
you can combine that with a preliminary
view of what the mechanism of action is
that's very sort of powerful um approach
which is enabled by the disc compare
analysis and so does this work in
practice and you can see here in this
example where where I'm screening a
number of different sty lines um one of
which and the rpmi8226 cell actually
expresses the V receptor too and this
compound here compound a is actually a
selective inhibitor of that so you can
see where even though you have a wide
range of different cancer cell lines
where you have a specific Target
mediated activity where you understand
what it is and you have a compound where
you understand it um its specificity you
can see a difference between between
this and other cell which don't express
this particular top so it is it is quite
useful and power
methodology um you can look at a um a
sort of a larger range of um outputs
from the compare analysis here we're
comparing for the standard compound CIS
platin and we profiled against 35 cell
lines if you compare it against the
standard set in compare which I think
the more about 170 so compounds you can
see
that the mechanism of action of the
Matched compounds or the correlated
compound comp are similar to that of CIS
Platinum CIS platin is a DNA
crosslinking compound you can see a pick
up CIS platin itself but also other
compounds with similar mechanism of
action if you then go ahead and compare
and RIS Platinum results against the
diversity set 38,000 you can see you
actually pick up M platin which is an
added consist platin but you also pick
up higher within the ranking this is
five out 38,000 compounds with similar
mechanisms of action which cross DNA so
you've got I think with the um the
compare analysis combined with the
phenotypic approaches of the cell typ
glow method you've got a very good way
of identifying um compound effects but
also getting a first view of the um
potential mechanisms of action but um
everything is not exactly perfect um so
that you can do a lot but there's other
things that we'd like to do we're really
interested in how we can potentially
improve this process and I think it's
fair to say ATP detection as with most
methods is not a universal reduct um
some cell growth and toxic toxicity
metum are not adequately reflected and
you can see this quite nicely I
encourage you to go and have a look at
this Hipp by chanit in in plus one um
and those guys found um particular
instances for and certain compounds
particularly those which are DNA
synthesis targeting agents such as gabin
and top the side those um those
compounds also cause increases in the
size of the cells and the mitochondrial
content of cells and in those cases the
consequence is that ATP determination
actually radically um
underestimates the the C toxic effects
of the compounds so you've got an issue
there for compon of a particular
mechanism of action it's not a universal
read I think also what's quite
interesting to be able to to get a
better handle on particularly an early
part of um profiling effort is what the
time dependence of the site IC effect is
that you're you're monitoring some
membrane disrupting agents and and sort
of nasty um compounds generally have
their effects within minutes or hours
whereas those such as Cy platin which
are DNA crosslinking um compounds they
they connetics happen over um several
tens of hours or even days and it's
extremely useful from our perspective to
be able to um identify which compounds
are acting rapidly which are potentially
a bit slower that might give you some
more information about the potential
mechanism action we can help or use that
information to help us in compound
prioritization I think there's a third
area um where some um non-atp detection
method for instance would give us a
benefit and you really want to sort of
eliminate some of the detection steps
and that you know on one level serves to
reduce reent costs but also as I've
shown earlier on they are assay
artifacts associated with some compounds
and for the instance of CIS plat for
instance it's it's Hing in the cter
screen so you want to avoid that
so what we've done is to um make use of
the fact that you can get the um the
stainfree or stainless Imaging
capability of the inside system and
here's some um experimental work that we
did again these are fairly small scale
linear experiments but some quite
interesting results in there for an mcf7
line which we seeded in two hours you
can see here and for two separate ples
you can see a steady increase in and the
confluency as observed using bright
field energy and that's you know quite
reasonable the measurement time is is
less than 4 minutes per plate which is
quite low so we're seeing you know quite
a nice assessment there of the kinetics
of the and the increase in cell
compeny now we we wanted to profile some
um some standard compounds one of those
is cult cin and cin is a compound which
affects cell mitosis by
inhibiting excuse me microtubular
polymerization and it does that by a
binding to the tubulate and these are
dose response curs concentration on the
bottom on the left hand side you can see
we got the cell TI of results um we've
got a ic50 around5 micro there
something
yeah an ic50 value of about 05 mic
microl there if we compare that to the
confluency measurement which comes up
from the bright field analysis you can
see you get a very similar ic50 value of
microl then interestingly if we look at
the cell roughness parameter which
norber has described earlier on you can
see again we get a nice do response
format with the and cell roughness
parameter increasing the compound
concentration and um an approximate i50
of about 02 microl and in some senses
the cell roughness parameter so in this
case appears to be um slightly more
sensitive to cight toxicity than either
the cell tip of glore or even the
confluency there could be a sense there
that we're we're picking up some some
earlier or more subtle cyto toxic
effects with with the cell roughness
parameter excuse
me so we can we repeat the same sets of
experiments using Arenal cell councel
line
7860 again with culing you can see here
we see pretty much the same results with
the c GL we're getting our classic um um
Cy static and cyot Toxic effect our
ic50s are about 06 microl we're getting
pretty much the same values with the
cell confluency measurement but with
cell roughness we're getting ic50s of
above 03 micro so it's looking a little
bit more sensitive but what's quite
thing is that you have um three
essentially completely oral readings
here they've got the cell tight of glow
analysis you've got your confluency
readout and you've got your cell
roughness readout and it's worth
pointing out that all of these
measurements took place in the same well
um first of all we we did the Imaging
side and then we and we added the
reagents for the um for the cell TI of
glow analysis so you can get orthogonal
readers from the same world and it's
it's to M plexing which is quite
exciting and quite useful
well um you can see here for um again
for the mcf7 breast cancer cell line
with another geming C toxic compound G
and violet Crystal Violet and you can
see in the cell technical analysis we've
got a a slightly slightly less important
compound 9.7 microl confluency is
looking a little bit more important 5.7
microl but cell roughness again is it's
quite a lot lower and we think again
there may be some an early hint of set
effects which are coming up on this C
this
parameter
so so I think in terms of an overview of
the performance of the and system and
based upon our work with it so far I
think the the bright field Imaging with
the inside certainly gives us um results
for cell confluency which are pretty
consistent with the data that we get
from ATP
determination um but it's done in a very
short time less than four minutes per
plate and without the need for
additional
reents what's particularly exciting from
my perspective so getting a lot of stuff
for free as it were these extracted
morical features such as cell R seem to
provide useful orthogonal secondary
reducts which may in some senses be more
sensitive than the stic law ATP
determination or the confluency
measurement um in our work so far the
the Imaging time has been around 4
minutes per plate and I think that's
quite important that the the Imaging
time is is short and we don't want the
plate to be sitting on the reader for
extended amounts of time so they AR with
the four minutes per plate we we don't
see any unnecessary perturbations to the
cells and they minimize and we have
looked at a couple of other cell lines
as well a549 and NDB and their data of
evaluation but the results so far show
that the optimization of the image
analysis algorithms to give you the
confluency measures and the r this
measures appears to be relatively
straightforward at least for for our
team here so I think what we want to do
ultimately is to be able to extend these
analysis to the full 35 panel 35 cell
lines that we have of the 60 and to show
it's a generally applicable methodology
in the way that's something like self
tactic laws as well so we don't want to
be um doing very bespoke um Creations
vage analysis algorithms and it doesn't
seem to be necessary it seems to be a
straightforward
process so where are we going next with
the insight and and and all of our sort
of collaborative work witha and we're
going to extend the image analysis
process to cover additional cell lines
and also non-cancer cell lines some
primary cell lines that we're interested
in as well um as I mentioned earlier on
I think compounds with um different
mechanisms of action we want to be able
to differentiate those in terms of the
time dependence and the onset of cyot
toxicity and differentiate between cyot
toxic and cell gold effects and what we
haven't been up to able to do until now
is to unequivocally differentiate
between a live cell and a dead cell in
stainless Imaging and we want to be able
to do that and I think we've getting a
strong indication that the and the cell
roughness parameter is the way to go
down and we want to be able to profile
compounds which have been described as
problematic in ATP determination or
endpoint assets those are compounds
which cause increases in cell size and
which cause increases in number density
of
mitochondria and essentially our our
medium-term goal is to be able to um
complement at first um our current um
cell TI grow ATP determination platform
but in the medium to long term to
replace that with stainless Imaging and
bright field illumination and use that
in a way whereby we can both monitor
self Liberation and the effects of
compass on on growth but also look at
subtle morphological changes which are
associated with cell death for instance
roughness and cyot toxicity so um thank
you very much and I'm going to pass back
to now okay thank you so so let me
summarize before we go to the question
section so here you find the summary on
the inside multim mode reader plus
Imaging I hope you have seen clearly
from the three of us and learned that by
combination of cell Imaging with labeled
and label free Technologies you can get
more predictive data and the DU
Discovery
process how you can improve your data
quality and reduce costs in sale based
SES and last but not least how the
inside plus the cell Imaging could give
you benefit and make it an instring uh
idal instrument for the use in
anti-cancer drug
Discovery for more information I'd like
to root you on our website perk.com
inssite more to to come on the side so
please watch out uh now I'd like to open
the floor for any questions just as a
reminder on the left side you find a
Q&A
box let's see what kind of questions you
have there's one sorry to to smile but
there's something about uh soccer so we
all like soccer and we are in Germany so
sorry I had to smile um any prediction
regarding the the the soccer team on
Sunday what shall I say I work for
Germany uh let's go back to the signs
um what objective can be accommodated in
the unit for Imaging that's a question
for
Nobert I'm not sure whether objectives
means objective lces in this
case I don't the the F factor is the
question yeah so we use for
magnification lens
here and uh the instrument is designed
for this magnification for this lens so
it would not be easy to exchange
it okay thank you very much next
question here can the Imaging Focus
accommodate round button worlds or do
you need flat plastic welds or glass
buttom
plates so we can work nicely with flat
plastic or glass button
plates um we have not yet the down
button plates I doubt that it will be
very
well that is a nice keyword for me just
as a comment um so we can use the Epic
glass plate and we can
read we can use it for label free
Technologies as well as for the cell
Imaging so really have a multiplexing
here um another question you have
mentioned the Imaging time is to be
under four
minutes does this only include the
acquisition or Does it include the data
analyze as well yeah that's the question
the data analysis runs in parallel to
the image acquisition and so far we did
not find any analysis that slowed down
the uh the total process so typically
analysis even faster than the uh than
the measurements
are thanks to a capella because this is
a very efficient calculation
machine okay more questions to come
here what are the minimum maximum
measurement time for a 96 or 384 World
plate depending on the measurement
mode I think it's again one for you
sorry we have to wait for your questions
the the fastest time of course is on the
Fly absorbance measurements that's
around 6 second or 7 seconds for 96 Val
plate measurement time and if I recall
correctly it's something like 12 seconds
or 13 seconds for 34 plate maximum
measurement time of course are any
long-term
kinetics labor free sometimes runs
overnight uh other essays can run over
days
okay here we have another one are
samples analyzed with different studies
as foressence absorbance Alpha
technology unfortunately not see the end
of the
question but yes they are we have
already seen data from film that combine
luminesence and imaging we have combined
label free and imaging very successfully
as well and you can of course also
combine other Technologies yeah just a
quick add on to that I think was also as
on you do have to use Clear bottom
plates for the Imaging which isn't
optimal obviously for for luminescence
but in the case of and these ATP
determin determination assets there's
signal there's sufficient signal that it
isn't beinging issue so you get about a
a Haring of the overall signal intensity
but normally you're dealing with several
hundred counts and it's not an isue okay
thank you next question do you have any
comparison
head-to-head between the inside and high
content like operator or Opera data
that's a very good point so in the
beginning we did some comparison studies
and we're quite pleased with the outcome
that enforces our strength and our
optimism that we have choosing the right
Optical design raised the good point
unfortunately we have not W it up such
that we could would show it here in the
seminar but we'll follow
up next
one lot of Imaging questions unfor no
questions for you Phil so far what I can
see are you able to image all four
colors simultaneously or is each Channel
acquired
sequentially again each channel is
acquired SE eventually by just changing
the exitation light source so you don't
need to change uh any filter in
between that's an explanation why we're
so fast yeah that's the reason being so
fast the Opera Phoenix uses up to four
different cameras to read simultaneously
different colors that would not fit into
the
inside let's take another
one is there any environmental control
temperature control or gas uh especially
that was the question it's important uh
for kinetic measurement of light
cells would you like to answer yeah I
can take so we have temperature control
on board and uh based on the studies
we've seen so far either with the
addition of certain buffer ingredients
which enables the cells to stay longer
as well well as uh long-term label free
assays really demonstrated clearly that
uh gas control is not required but if
you run it in automatic fashion I think
there was a point raised by th yeah you
can comment so I think it it depends on
on the time scale of your contic event
so you know this is not a flipper system
for instance you're not adding a calcium
solution or adding a salt solution for a
calcium flux um I think this is suited
for observing kinetic effects that c
take place over an hour's time scale and
I think that that's quite good in for
that and but you would need potentially
some form aimation with um an adjacent
incubator to feed cell plates into there
so you have the know potential
disadvantage that you can't control
while it's on the on the plate while
it's on on the reader but you have the
potential advantages that you could
sequentially screen many plates with
cycle times of an hour or two hours
between them so it's kinetic a slightly
longer time I would
say okay thank you very much next
question a very simple one what is the
primary difference between the operator
and the inside if I want to do high
content very simple as I pointed out in
the introduction the inside is capable
to read cells at cellular resolution so
if you are interested in simple essays
life de SES counting the inside is the
method of choice if you want to go
subcellular sub cellular high content
then the operti is the right instrument
to choose yeah so the the the that's
important in addition on inside you have
the avability of conventional MMD
Technologies let's go for the next one
ah here's something about something for
Phil during the ATP detection probably
there were some differences on this
detection with this future
differences
uh would it be a signal for
diagnosis um I I think what we're
looking for with the um using the the
bright field Imaging and is and you know
potentially as well as the digital phase
Imaging is to differentiate between live
and dead cell um populations but whether
you could use it as a um as a diagnostic
test I think that would be um a little
bit beyond beyond his capabilities
you need sort of um a different kind of
setup for diagnostic test but certainly
for um drug Discovery applications I
think will be a really interesting and
useful alternative to um to using ATP
techology thank you very much Phil this
was the last question we have a lot of
question we make sure that we uh answer
your question while email so thank you
very much for joining this morning or
this afternoon in the US and Europe uh
we wish you a nice day thank you very
much and uh have a nice day byebye
byebye thank
you